the u.s podcast industry made one and a
half billion dollars from advertising
last year that makes it sound like a
bonanza but the reality is a lot more
complicated the lockdowns were good for
the podcast industry in 2019 275 million
people listen to a podcast at least once
a month last year that had increased to
384 million and this year is going to
hit 424 million
the problem is that the number of
podcasts increased more quickly
pre-pandemic spotify hosted 450 000
podcasts now it's about 2.9 million in
other words there was a 540 percent
increase in the number of podcasts but
just a 40 increase in the size of the
audience
why is that well partly it's to do with
spotify's business model in music
streaming it has to give about 75 of
revenue straight to the record labels
it's only fair it's the labels and their
musicians who actually produce the music
but it also explains why spotify has
never posted a profit on a net basis
since it became a public company
spotify's solution has been to pivot
more towards podcasts on the whole they
have a fixed cost that doesn't increase
in lockstep with the number of listeners
that's why it's hiring big names like
joe rogan prince harry and meghan markle
the idea is that it moves more towards a
model similar to netflix's and of course
in podcasts you can make money twice
from the subscription fee and
advertising but if it's a good deal for
spotify is it also a good deal for those
millions of podcasts well the market is
tough yes advertising revenue is
increasing but not as quickly as the
number of new podcasts back in 2019 u.s
podcast advertising revenue hit 708
million dollars equivalent to about one
and a half million dollars per podcast
now that's more than doubled to one and
a half billion dollars but it averages
out to just five hundred thousand
dollars per podcast
and of course in reality very few people
are making anything near that sort of
money most the value is concentrated
towards the top of the pyramid the long
tail of small podcasts with small
audiences barely make any income at all
that's put a real premium on
discoverability or how easy it is to
find your show and it's also made apple
and spotify into gatekeepers there's a
bit of a conflict of interest there of
course because apple and spotify both
produce their own content too they have
both the opportunity and the incentive
to give their own shows preferential
treatment here's matt deegan the
creative director of folder media which
produces some podcasts
will
the curatorial places on spotify become
more about spotify originals than they
do about the party content now i don't
think i'll ever go 100 but you know
already probably 20 of curatorial is is
is to spotify and
spotify don't produce nearly anything
like 20 of the big podcasts out there
there's also little stopping them from
following the playbook pioneered by
social media companies about a decade
ago brands and public figures alike were
encouraged to build public profiles with
the promise they'll be able to reach
huge audiences but over time the
algorithm was tweaked meaning that you
might have a million followers but you'd
only perhaps reach one percent of them
if you didn't pay for more prominent
placement
that's also now the risk for podcasters
that it starts to become paid to play
spotify is already doing this in the
music space artists can pay to promote
their new releases
in turn that's why audio giants like the
bbc and luminary are building their own
apps they don't want to be beholden to
the whims of the gatekeepers there's a
real contest for your ears and they're
turning up the volume
[Music]
you